est-ce qu'on peut tuer quelqu'un en lui
soufflant dans le pénis bon là j'imagine
que tu fais référence à la vidéo dans
laquelle j'explique que un vagin n'est
pas un instrument avant on ne souffle
pas dedans donc on a vu que c'est
dangereux de souffler dans un vagin mais
dans un
pénis dans le cas du vagin ce qui est
dangereux c'est de souffler beaucoup
d'air d'un coup parce que ça peut se
retrouver soit dans le ventre la plupart
du temps soit carrément dans la
circulation sanguine en cas de grossesse
mais si on souffle dans un pénis il y a
pas ces risques là déjà parce que là on
souffle dans l'urêre c'est le trou du
pipi et l'urêre il est pas relié au
ventre il est relié à la vessie et puis
surtout parce que l'urêre c'est un tout
petit tuyau il est trop étroit et en
plus il est trop long pour qu'on puisse
envoyer plein d'air d'un coup donc je
dirais a priori pas de danger mais je
vais pas vous mentir j'ai pas trouvé
d'études scientifiqu FiBL hein donc dans
le doute ne faites pas ça si vraiment
vous aimez souffler dans des trucs
achetez-vous une
flute